ausschreitungen in düsseldorf rechte
hooligans haben sich am
sonntagnachmittag unter die querdenker
dämonische laut polizei habe sich der
veranstalter an die beamten gewandt und
darum gebeten etwa 80 personen aus dem
demonstrationszug zu entfernen
sie wurden eingekesselt und dann zu
einem nahen bahnhof eskortiert
man hat uns von seiten der
veranstaltungsleitung auch darum gebeten
diese personen hier aus dieser
demonstration zu entfernen dem sind so
nachgekommen wurde ganz klar auch hier
angetreten dass wenn die leute unter den
versuchen oder dem schutz der
demonstrationsfreiheit straftat oder
gewalttaten zu verüben dass wir
konsequent den die einschreiten
das hat der vereinzelt störungen gegeben
genau gehen ihre personengruppen wurde
dann auch konsequent eingeschritten
auch wasserwerfer wurden aufgefahren ein
polizeihubschrauber überwachte den
einsatz aus der luft für die
demonstration am sonntag in düsseldorf
waren ursprünglich 20.000 teilnehmer
angekündigt die zahl wurde dann jedoch
vom veranstalter auf nur 1000 korrigiert
gegendemonstranten des bündnisses
düsseldorf stellt sich quer versammelten
sich an verschiedenen orten in der
innenstadt unter ihnen auch vertreter
von kirchen gewerkschaften krankenhaus
und pflegepersonal sowie
kulturschaffende vom bündnis
düsseldorfer appell dass sich gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit und rassismus
wendet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren